new details are emerging about another
scandal facing the Catholic Church the
trial began today of two former
executives of a Vatican own Children's
Hospital they are charged with diverting
nearly a half million dollars in
hospital donations the money was
allegedly used to renovate the luxurious
retirement home of a Cardinal Seth Doane
is outside the Vatican of what this
means for the church and the Pope's
fight against corruption
Seth good morning good morning the
scandal has all of the makings of a
crime novel you have that hospital you
have the highest levels of the Catholic
Church and accusations of embezzlement
all at a time when the Pope is trying to
be seen as cracking down on corruption
two former executives from the Vatican's
bambino jesu Hospital its president and
treasurer went on trial this morning
facing criminal charges of embezzlement
it's alleged they siphoned off nearly
half a million dollars of money raised
for the Children's Hospital to renovate
the apartment of Cardinal torches Ober
Tony Toni had been the Vatican's number
two its Secretary of State under Pope
Benedict the former hospital president
Giuseppe prophy teep argues the
renovations were an investment because
Cardinal Bertone a was going to let the
hospital use his place for fundraising
events the Cardinal has not been charged
and insists he did not know about the
money being diverted to the Vatican own
Department a scandal like this really
placed the stereotype of out of touch
arrogant cardinals growing fat on the
wealth of the church Candida moss a
professor of theology at the University
of Notre Dame says this comes as Pope
Francis has been trying to fight
corruption Francis and the Vatican
really need this trial because their
moral credibility and their financial
stability are at stake if we don't see
results in this trial if we don't see a
prosecution people will wonder if
Francis is really serious about
financial reforms bambino Jesu is one of
the leading pediatric centers in Europe
First Lady Melania Trump visited in May
and speaking to hospital staff in
December Pope Francis said one of the
worst
cancers in a hospital is corruption
the Pope wants his trial because it
shows transparency and the idea that no
one is above the law
one Vatican insider told me that this is
the Pope airing the church's dirty
laundry in public in a way we just
haven't seen before Yana continued
pressure and controversy for the Vatican
Seth Doane in Rome thank you